[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment or a weekly anime newscast
the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments
starting things off with a quick anime
upper announcement it's only been just
over a week since we first started our
patreon and we already have our first
five patrons so a huge thank you to sha
tous a lovely tune today Gilgamesh
third-strike senado if that's how he
pronounces it and also to my boy
Christian Fleur
thank you everybody for your support if
you're in the discord be sure to message
Anna Mae upper so I can give your
special roles and if you want to check
out our patreon the link is in the
description maybe the biggest news of
this past week is that a new trailer for
the Tokyo ghoul live-action movie has
just been released this trailer is
pretty short however from what I could
see it looks pretty good to me and I'm
especially impressed with the casting
the casting looks pretty great in my
opinion but what do you think let me
know what you think about the trailer
down below I will leave a link to it in
the description also be sure to let me
know if you think that this live-action
adaptation is going to be actually worth
watching we all know the history of
anime live-action adaptations however I
did really like the Death Note Japanese
live-action adaptations I thought again
the casting was great I enjoy them so
yeah let me know what you think does
this Tokyo ghoul adaptations stand a
chance and an anime opera news for this
week back on Saturday we uploaded a very
special video about Fukui also known as
fooly cooly and FLCL in this video I
addressed the major theme of childhood
and growing up versus adulthood and the
expectations of the adult world in fully
cooley which first aired in the year
2000 but has since become a huge cult
classic anime and to be honest this is
probably the one video that I am most
proud of so far I was really excited to
do it and I was inspired to do it after
re-watching fooly cooly recently and i
think it turned out really well
i got personal and emotional i think a
bit at the end but yeah I had a blast
doing it I'm really proud of it and be
sure to check it out guys and other news
we learned that Anna Plex is going to be
making an english-language dub of the
anime on Ohana which is supposed to come
out sometime this summer now personally
I really love
it is one of my favorite romance and
coming-of-age anime however I'm not a
big fan of dubs to begin with so I'm not
too excited about this news however if
you are excited let me know down in the
comments and I will leave a quick teaser
for the dub in the description where you
hear a little preview of Menma
so let me know if you like it down below
now my good buddy and fellow rent cafe
member Briggs from all-day anime has
been doing an amazing job recently on
his channel his channel has been growing
quickly and has been making some really
high quality videos his videos on the
seven deadly sins anime have been
especially successful but he's been
making a whole bunch of other videos as
well including a my hero academia video
collaboration with 2spooky a few days
ago Briggs uploaded a video explaining
the different races of all of the seven
deadly sins and the video is already
doing great I will leave a link in the
description be sure to check it out
great job Briggs and another fellow rent
cafe members simply Rose who hasn't been
on rent cafe for a while because of her
big move to Korea is back that's right
everybody simply Rose is back uploading
regular videos after she finally was
able to get Internet in her new
apartment in Korea Rose as uploading
interesting vlogs from Korea along with
reviews of seasonal anime like attack on
Titan in my hero academia so be sure to
check out her channel she even made a
special video on her channel apologizing
to everyone for not being more active
during the move however Rose you have no
reason to apologize we're glad you're
back and we'll be watching your channel
and my favorite amv for this week is a
recreator SE MV called lose my life by
ali rose MV i will actually be starting
re-creators this week because so many of
you guys recommended it to me and this
MV really got me pumped up to watch it
so be sure to check it out and that is
it for this week guys if you enjoyed
these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]